all right
it's 11:30 1:00 p.m. on Wednesday
November something well Lex was not here
to tell me what day it is November 20th
soon to be November 21st waiting for a
game I'm Lee joining the Super blitz
arena there are 58 minutes left let's go
there and let's play let's play gambit
every game this tournament starting with
the Danish gambit a Danish gambit
declined but I'll try and still let my
opponent accept it
yeah keep taking pawns keep taking pawn
so you can take this or this now play
Knight g5 95 will be a good move from
black I'm 95 95 Bishop b3 and then maybe
f4 with tempo also Queen b3 ideas d5
giving me back upon I'll throw in a
Rocha I'm gonna have a queen check to
hitting this c6 defends both the king
and the knight c6 g6 it gets weird see
66 o'night c63 night free pawn ok I like
the position I like the number of people
in the chats music man Johan Johnny
franchise whoa let's be careful let's
take another free pawn everything in
life is free be x17 vemma tix 1 welcome
back
12 in chess welcome back shadow to 12 in
chess who very
what's the right word very generously
created a Wikipedia page for me in
English and in German I should make a
wiki command what to take with I can
take with multiple things probably rook
oh there's gonna be a smothered mates
wait for it wait for it rook takes off
seven Queen takes off seven King eh eh
Queen g8 rook takes g8 knight of seven
eights I have to play it on the analysis
board just to have some satisfaction
there we go okay I'm satisfied back to
tournaments 170 no time to waste unless
his first smothered mate I have a lot of
catching up to do
that was my first game leader has played
many more games than me
chess lovers Sanjeev welcome back okay
Joe check let's preserve the game with
the e5 Oh every game a gambit I'll
gamble by each pawn somehow let's play
d5 I'll gambit something at some point
eventually or I'll just what to do
efore is a move let's play Bishop c5
maybe g5 g4 to trap the bishop combined
with Queen f6 to me a ton of - yeah I'm
Gavin in this pond
not sure what benefit I I get if white
takes
maybe this anonymous ooh not sure what
to do about that let's just develop a
night's and undeveloped a night and
probably redevelop the nights maybe I
should move up getting ready to push I
got out of the pin hmm that's a move
play this move I still want to do this G
pawn push if Y never castles I am
dreaming of mating on G - yeah cuz now
the night spin to the rook play f6
always playoff six it's not Queen trade
now the Queen will be a target I want to
play Knight d6 why don't top-level
players play gambits they're probably
too afraid I take some some guts to play
gambits also sometimes gambits are
dubious at top levels okay I want to
play this move but not it was a bishop
my trapping a queen
the Queen's trapped because I'm
controlling these squares the square the
square the square the square the square
and there's this move that could
actually be a strong move
hopefully my opponents not watching the
stream
hmm
yeah why it might actually be better
here but no one say anything okay
free queen night takes before coming
plenty of time chassé bran will come
back threatening the fork Knights let's
play this move the triple skewer kebab I
mean d5 okay let's take a knight
threatening the rook now threatening the
Knights also threatening the fork
I can draw heroes the triple fork ah
okay
arrows are failing me um let's save the
queen
pinning the pot this pawns hanging let's
take a check
now the pawns pinned to the the rook
okay who's here in the chats we have
faba oxy we have check raise flops hello
to the Future YouTube people that's
right future YouTube people you can like
I can comment I can subscribe back to
tournaments okay
where am I I don't see me oh there I am
top hundred let's go not sure how many
more games I'll have I'll probably have
more coconut water than games as
tournament exams are coming but yeah I'm
more important than exams work again
gambit I'm play a staffer gambit
hopefully oh my opponent playing a
gambits let's play the f5 counter
gambits whatever this is oh this is
gonna be really bad this is gonna be
really bad okay
opponent in play Queen h5 which would
have destroyed me d5 is a move Queenie
Savin maybe this phone in the night so I
don't lose upon the h5 still a movement
than g6 i rooks defended by my queen I
mean white could force a Queen trade
which is probably what's happening yeah
okay so we'll trade stuff I'm gonna try
and win this pawn it could be defended
by a 4 mm okay I'll take upon this pawns
hard to defend
takes takes doesn't really do that much
I should save the bishop here so
calculating before this this d5 over
than this so maybe I'll Castle first
hitting f2 threatening d5 removing the
Knights like I'm going off to still play
d5 maybe Knight see for coming III is
kind of weak there's about five also
coming what to do Bishop d7 night c4
looks Pleasant III is a gaping hole I'm
down upon but I have comp so I have two
bishops I have open e file
I better developments it's um it's like
I play the cam bit okay now my Knights
attacking stuff I have d4 in the
position D for D 494 I could just
develop Bishop D 494 yeah let's throw it
and the bishop will come to e6 whoa my a
four I'll still put my Bishop there if
we trade on b6 but a file would become
open to do it's like Kings you sodding
it safe move g5 not yet maybe you later
g5 doesn't make too much sense okay I
want to take in an attack let's add
pressure all this pawns hanging but og5
now g5 just fork over it loses a pawn
but I'm gambling I don't know why I gave
away g5 aha what to do
20 seconds okay let's take that night a
for defending g6
see five ideas never mind
not pleasant rule-free Brooke very
pleasant very very pleasant okay I'm
taking things one pawn at a time both
these pawns are hanging I'll take
another pawn well it subs woke over
gifting subs thanks so much Kover maybe
it was because of g5 I dedicated took
over meat in three one two and oh just
wait no that's not meat
this still takes work ah I have two
rooks versus one rock okay everything's
defended at least me coming
I got opposition and game strategy let's
do this move huh
that's annoying maybe this move yeah
I'll trade rooks this will be nice oh
wait a pony tricked me mate in next move
okay I was a weird game got the job done
thanks so much Culver I think my
appointment may have Mouse slipped at
some point their covert gifting subs to
Ritter rid or silly mash mystery Sabin
and Joe cool music and the last Seven
Samurai last Seven Samurai is a
grandmaster probably my my highest rated
subscriber now thanks so much again
Kover I wear shoes welcome back hope
nagels welcome back double conducts for
subbing I'll boat one two three a jerk
let's take four and let's gambit let's
play a new game 'but that will greater
halloween let's play belgrade haven't
played belgrade gambit in the wild
I had that one YouTube video winning in
12 moves it's gonna be hard to repeat
what does this move let's take a pawn if
not here then all four nights in the
center unlikely though okay I like the
position controlling the center let's to
do I mean there's Queenie five kind of
winds up on take that work out fate wait
I take this am I gonna win in less than
twelve moves
I might Wow look at this position it's
so beautiful
oh I'm not this is move eleven I have to
win the next move
maybe opponent will be nice and resign
in c4 let's defend stuff mainly in the
night I want to play Bishop each three
you need one more straw to break the
camel's back let's play this move
between h3 I'm controlling the dark
squares the main gather way squares
um digit III looks nice
okay it's not a twelve move victory but
it's something I mean the Kings on e6
one of the most centralized pieces for
black I think I'll Castle and just
improve the position wow that's a fork
yeah let's take a look Queeny sudden I
played let's check I'll take a knight's
castle okay I'm up a lot of material I'm
up a knight and a rook and a pawn mmm
always play King be one well I have a
free pawn okay that will be ooh to do 56
Queen have four ideas let's take a pause
okay now the e-files open this bishop is
a dead piece like when h7 looks nice i
lokking trade Queens with Queen f5 but
maybe not okay this is too much fun Oh
where's a mate to bring the other rook
in and Queen h8 okay we're gonna trade
Queens let's meet this way I guess
so the bishops still stuck try and
control the getaway squares b3 for good
measure play this move okay after
tournaments Belgrade success z nation
will come back andraia tried to raid me
and accidentally raided the wrong Eric
Rosen no Andrea to learn from your
mistakes
don't make the same mistake twice
there's another Eric Rosen maybe there
is
okay xx play 16 points I am oh I'm
halfway to the lead let's play another
gambit i bezerk accept my opponents
high-rated what to do what some let's
accept the gambits ooh what is this okay
this is probably slightly dubious for me
I have to deal with it though Queen B 3
Queen d7
and then 95 I thinks the move hopefully
this works it takes and then this move
or no this move
let's get the King safe Oh II 5 coming
you 5 not played it's still a bit
uncomfortable let's try and trade
Queen's Bishop e6 to come well it's
still uncomfortable I mean I could
accept very bad pawn structure and a
very bad bishop oh dear take stakes 97
here it takes 97 immediately my plans
are actually it's gonna be so sad
but I have two bishops double pawns
I see the pawns everywhere Oh what to do
it's trying to avoid vomiting
well it's play King g7 first I don't
know what to do here 35 seconds just
have to move quickly quickly
let's play the smooth um b2 is kind of
hanging should play a 43 keep pushing
keep pushing
hey thanks for the bits Kenny I have a
connect for emotes yes you're welcome
okay I want to go from behind win the
pawn and promote my pond I'll opponent
being tricky I guess I have to take it
and then let's attack the pawn also
threatening this let's take that turning
this mm-hmm
attacking the knight
well more subs thanks more subs it's
gonna be tricky
don't flag I know I know I know I know
I'm trying I wanna play this move next
also this one maybe 14 seconds strong
player to play this move ooh
probably not a great decision it should
still be winning but it's gonna be
tricky
Knights are very tricky line game hey at
least I have a clear plan
keep pushing gave Bishop blockades are
you choking there
still tricky that's a safe cream if I
want to play this next
no we drew I think I was winning that -
I had like a second left okay
a new game let's play the Blackmore
Deemer Oh what is this my dad
okay I'm playing whatever this is a
reverse walrus maybe reverse walrus I
can live with this
IG five ideas D fives a move to retreat
I would be happy to lift my rook the
opponent wants to take the Knights
that's probably a good move now you sack
more stuff like on g6 maybe Queen Queen
f3 looks nice yeah why not trying to
provoke a six a black and Castle g4
doesn't work oh this is just a really
bad position
where's my play I don't see my play
let's take a thing and then rook okay
Brooke could be one making f1 soon i
preserved too
so material deficit time deficits um
let's play Bishop like a special f4 I'm
losing more material after E 5 I might
be play Queen g3 and I Square for the
Queen aligned with the king
u5 good move looking for tactics I don't
see tactics to move back
probably back again now this is really
bad
oh I have a thread of this maybe the
ship takes h5 takes in 96 discoveries it
takes here I take here to attack the
Queen opponent being safe maybe Quinn h2
idea g4g for h5 ideas my berserk you
automatically yes every game buzzer King
also every game gambit oh this is
looking really bad but okay I gotcha
foreign I want to open up files like my
pieces are all kind of looking passive
but they're doing things
mmm to move takes takes mmm
I'm not seeing a solution to this it's
Queen h3 now let's take okay well at
least open the the G file some Bishop f4
idea hmm
I can take this thing okay I'm waiting
back pawns at least let's take this
thing Cairo team I wanna I wanna play h5
just make the bishop go away so I can
get to the king ah forgot about that
this is really bad again okay at least
I'm winning something back let's take
this thing tomorrow no that came to d2
the rook somewhere I don't lie time is
bad again no opponent missed a fork
so slightly uncomfortable hmm this is
very uncomfortable after I go for a
dirty flag ha ha
it's so sad there goes all my reading I
tried my best tried my best I missed
something maybe I missed something there
man so many F's ok I'll try and make up
for it am i anywhere close to first
place I'm actually or I lost a second
place person all right I just want one
staff again that just one okay we'll
have a four nights I'll play this kind
of dumb opening the Schmid defense idea
queenie 7-pin the night so many apps
yeah Paulin had a few ways to win that
the previous game okay we're having
something in Queen c5 next swing well
Bishop takes in this move I think I'm
winning a bishop now one's gonna try in
like pin me hey Bishop d7 to f6 maybe
there should be six ideas okay turning
this now
one's probably gonna play this move
Bishop III could still do this let's do
now let's keep the Queen nice very
crowded efile not sure what's going on
there the plan is this in castle
oh there's Bishop there's Bishop d4 but
then Queen g5 I want a castle it's like
a totem pole yeah can I have the d5
square for this Bishop I still count
castle but that's okay
maybe I'll push the H pawn in
conjunction and I'll target g2 a for
kind of random we're both kind of doing
our own things let's do this move now
the goal is to do this in this whoa play
this move now the goal is to do this in
this my king is still relatively safe
it's safer with a pawn here rather than
the pawn like not on the board
well okay I can take and Bishop c5 mmm
then take again anything better
not seeing it I don't play Queen g3 I
want to play h3 next white noise welcome
back Clippers like the people who make
twitch clips Clippers oh there's work a3
don't play your okay three don't do it
told my opponent not to do it okay still
wanna play each three though whoo free
rock I also play age three firsts those
rooks is gonna be stuck for a little bit
G three push up on and take upon ya the
rooks pinned now I can trade everything
I can still legally castle both ways
maybe I haven't moved either a king or
rook but eventually I'm gonna have to
move something it's not this way I'm
trying this really no way to stop it
okay back to tournaments I have any
chance there's 29 minutes left 25th
place 21 points leader has 35 points I
need to berserk and win out gonna be
tough some fancy potato welcome to
twitch congratulations for catching a
stream only played before if if I play
Sicilian yeah III this is something so
we can get it let's take this push up on
white noise there's an NBA team called
the Clippers huh
did not know that alleys shouldn't know
that it's like when h5 it's already
getting weird maybe I'll just keep
pushing pawns f-4c for g4 coming from
the Queen back place III and G for
winning connect for you guys can use the
Kinect for emotes yeah okay g5 let's go
just fork over and in c4 I'll win Kinect
for again yeah
what is this five maybe is this let's
play Bishop much of a three to use my
other pieces video game pianists thanks
for the raid appreciate that if you're
just joining my pawns are kind of
grinning a nice little grin shape let's
keep developing and defending maybe
Knight d2 coming take with rook
attacking this pawn and I'll take upon
although there's this move does that
work no that doesn't work let's take and
want the night to come here someday
start with this such a weird position my
King feels unsheltered let's move off
the diagonal a going to go mad thank you
for the sub um what to do f5 dad like my
smiling structure is gonna be ruined
soon okay let's take first five
take stakes well it's a move let's play
oh dear this move it's getting weird
takes takes takes takes stuff is
happening my king is becoming more and
more exposed mm-hmm still playable my
knight is my my main shelter for the
king and this move I could castle its
castle never too late to castle
attacking the knight getting out of the
pin to block copying me play Knights oh
let's take her Knights forgot the knight
was hanging searching for meeting ideas
this move defending I want to play this
move and then later this move from 12
seconds why am i so long time yes
because I deserved to play this move I
might have five ideas
Queen f3 ideas I hang d4 but that's okay
well I hang e for two weights oh this is
bad
oh this is good this is really good
okay back to tournaments let's go 18th
place 24 minutes left 24 tournament
points I have to catch up by 15 points
whoa 2809 it's really hard to catch up
to so maybe I'll try and finish top
three maybe I'd see eight thanks for the
bits Evans gambit please lol okay
just because you say lol out who's gantu
time please beserk back please be nice
not even in Evans gambit okay what is
this I don't know what to do h4 h5 h6
ideas t4 ideas - this is reasonable
I'm discouraging this cuz I have a chief
for you Rick p1 open file for the rook
Oh gamma ding a pawn okay that's my
gambit for this game
Oh if Bishop here I can take takes and
then here I think a get Mader show this
once please play Bishop g4 have some fun
I'd see six more likely
or that all I have rook takes b7 as a
threat that's some nasty threat play h6
be nice yes
oh it's like a voodoo doll okay
there should be five coming the bishop
takes here I've win the Queen by force
so what's happening what is blocking to
do I know it's blocks gonna do oh I
didn't know I thought black was gonna
play a six um can I get away with this
they are there there if I played there
should be five my route gets trapped
that's a problem like here here it takes
takes takes here it almost works it
doesn't quite work how I justify my rook
on b7 should be five not seeing it I
guess I'll just retreat all the way back
it's kind of sad but I want a pawn I
open the file
there should be five still looming I
want to play d4 Bishop f4 target the
Queen Black has a couple checks but then
it interferes with the e pawn ePHI of
all play d4 there should be five next
there's about four necks before most
likely I guess play Bishop e5 taking
Queen g3 some rook b8 ideas Bishop f4 is
still coming actually takes maybe I'll
play rook b8 first I'm not sure some
perpetual somewhere
it's also takes Queenie five check it's
interesting there should be seven takes
for a cafe and then takes here the time
is levelling up Wow
let's start with this move rook b8 will
come later this bishops tied down to the
pawns pawn can't really push each pawn
is doing work I can take a pawn ooh
let's move to the back move the bishop
back I'll block lost castling rights
play this move good Sacko Queen take my
queen oh do I take here oh but then King
e7 I'll take the bishop first okay I
want to move my rook somewhere let's
move the Queen here let's play this move
okay my rook has moved somewhere mission
accomplished kind of it's check check
check check
oh that game was a fun game lots of fun
luo zhixiang
favorite move that game it's probably
rook takes be sevens also prompting my
opponent to play each six okay's ever to
play I still want to Stafford gambit no
one everyone's playing d4 f4 okay I'll
play Alf all Kabir counter gambits this
is fun opening d3 the main move Bishop
c4 is a move
okay now I'll control the diagonal I'll
play Bishop f5 first defend the pawn and
prepared Knight g4 take on Toussaint in
Queen d7 I still want to play Knight g4
in 13th place that's a move can't really
do much about that to play this try and
keep initiative Queens are off the board
mm yeah that's annoying we're trading a
lot that doesn't even work let's play
this move
okay a lot of things came off the board
let's play this move attack the pawn
Castle bring the rook here before I'll
move back Rd below a minute play this
move this move
let's still a little bit of conversation
I'm gonna play c5 let's say I wanted to
play Knight g4 - but nevermind
hey rook b1 yeah
okay we're trading more stuff it's kind
of sad
I'm still trying to fight let me down
the pawn play a four good move play this
move going for counter-attack
kind of destroying my own pawn structure
but I'm attacking this and this okay I
have a fork back in the game I take with
Brooke probably and then this move I'll
sneak in from behind yeah okay now
threatening this probably also this the
kings of it's stuck the King's tied down
to defending the bishop it's very hard
to stop this yeah I think I'm just
winning the bishop oh not yet but
eventually like White's gonna be in
zugzwang right White's gonna beans legs
long everything is pinned tied down I'll
walk my king this way the rook can move
back and forth that doesn't really help
with pawn here I take King here I take
it's a funny kind of dueling position
that's so random my weights just stuck I
do have 23 seconds but should be enough
time I'm gonna win the bishop at some
point
if King takes c5 I'll take with Knights
I think
this is so nice okay now I'll win the
bishop cleanly trade I'll take a four
and push the pawn
okay back to tournament let's go
top ten seven place berserk no master no
one's buzzer 'king back okay let's play
my my line this might not be a gambits
but try and make it fun I'll play a six
maybe white wins a pawn takes takes
takes I know I would attack the rook in
the end a3 is a move Bishop g4 a move
Bishop g4 there there looks like too
much fun
f3 takes takes takes takes Knight d5
looks kind of cool umm let's save the
bishop but I can't really save it so
effectively without losing a pawn mm-hmm
yeah let's just do this and then
probably this okay I'm Gavin aji pawn
there's my gambit or even this pawn but
if takes this point I think I can take
here and then take here it takes here I
play this and then maybe when g2 later
okay opponent going for it hmm I want to
take on e3 for some reason sort of this
move finding this because of the f1 is
pinned
if this is weakening till the light
squares I'll be Queen h5 okay time to
take on your three working G 2 and D 1
this is nice
it was very nice hey there's a nice
emote why a nice shadow to a sermon
always having nice emotes so Queen d2
takes o work ta coming this is more nice
than I originally thought I take that
okay let's start with this because
queenside castling was illegal I want to
take on f2 and the fish of D 4 C 5 here
I can take on a 2b c 5 first not sure no
time to think
let's take here and then trying to
calculate rook F 1 there there I mean
this looks very nice
okay 91 why not invading the back rink
there's a cool meeting idea Queen oh
wait where does the Queen move Queen g3
if Queen g3 there's a very cool mating
idea
I think I'm tagging the Queen just on
the back rank Queen d2 I take that can't
quite take it I wanted to do something
cool let's do this I'm not winning
material oh man I have to take that oh
this is gonna be tough there goes all of
my have to flay now we're in an end game
wanna play b65 pawn count is equal or no
I'm up a pawn somehow
it's slightly unpleasant Oh opponent
tricked me lonely tricked me good oh
that's so sad
likes my position - okay I need hope
probably no hope
yeah I resign ah such a there is a
really cool amazing idea um in this
position after 91 if Queens III I can
take on c2 and then real t1 mates I've
been so sweet
yeah Queen d2 I guess it neutralizes
everything I wanted to take here idea of
takes rook t1 mates but Bishop takes I
guess there's just nothing it's sad yeah
91 not the best move probably should
have played c5 okay let's try and finish
strong
c5 was a just a more direct move
what do I have to do I have to do a lot
of things I'll try and finish reasonably
next game
I bet Queen like Queen sak coconuts
yeah this is coconut water not exactly
tea Evans gambit I don't even play that
Evans gambit okay I'm Evans gambit
Incans Bishop e7 Oh what is this a for I
guess to play be fine there should be
two maybe this is like a Evans gambit
declined with a six a four included
Peter Baugus thanks for rating
appreciate that child to Peter let's
play this move is Evans attacks and how
does block defend can black defend I
teach six I can take it there's a v6 I
take it okay let's take here we need to
looks very nice the Queen has a
long-distance relationship with the
bishop should probably defend play this
move the threat is maybe Bishop g6 funny
idea a bishop here even just to clear f7
so g6 anything better
mmm he's gonna play d5 maybe I take
first but then takes my bishop g6
d5 takes ya Oh a night of seven there we
go okay I was looking for mating ideas I
wasn't looking for forking ideas oh this
is a fork and I should win the rook
pretty cleanly no castle no time for
castling too busy winning rooks oh this
is a move
okay good thing opponent didn't play
that there's pawns pinned to the meeting
square mmm it's challenge of the night
93 is a legal move okay lots of trades
I think the bishop wants to come here
play e5 first know maybe this move ideas
of taking yeah I'm up a full rook Wow
King
that's King f2 it gets okay
I don't play rook e1 mess Queen here I
have bishop here oh I'm still okay yeah
let's the not the knight is useful
defending the bishop from the corner and
I'm threatening meets Queenie ideas
hitting the King what to do next
oh let's take a bishop no g4 why not I
just want to move the Queen away from
defending the g6 Square Queen g4 combo
okay well I'm up before rook 7th heaven
a5 positional I want to play this next
[Music]
this is looking nice I just got my pawn
up to help out also I should blockade
this fun maybe you win the pond first
I'll start with g5 and then let's move
let's take this thing okay mm-hmm maybe
time for a game or two more trying to
move up its beserk again oh I'm in sixth
place okay I mean within striking
distance of third place hmm I don't know
what this should be full before his but
it looks aggressive let's take this bd6
I'll opponent playing aggressively yeah
I want to win the e5 pawn or play d6 Yap
in and win threatening to take and then
Bishop d4 okay so I'll win material
don't have a meeting attack but this is
good enough
wanna play e4 next yeah why not
if takes I'll probably take back
you know the bishop and I are hanging
I'll win one of them
my goal is still top three it's gonna be
difficult
hmm one safe move maybe g6 next just
make some lift
mmm tricky play the smooth ha my rook I
hung a rook Smartcar thanks for subbing
da points smart enough let's defend
everything g6 coming next
ooh tricky to play me this move giving
away material that going for meats I was
probably not the best idea
I'll force a queen trade that's a
winning king bonding oops some
questionable pre moves there
okay back to tournaments oh okay
I'm close to passing a loosey jerk again
I don't know why I'm buzzer King trying
to induce my opponent to bezerk 98
thanks for the 200 bits okay this will
be interesting
I'll play e5 knight c6 I think Bishop b5
Queen okay yeah we're just gonna have a
standard position I'll play b4 hmm
this is actually interesting line Knight
takes d5 pawn takes d5 Bishop takes a
one queen takes a one okay I'll play
Bishop III play Knight b5 you rook rook
t1 Queen's gonna move to the D file or
the B file play this move I do want to
attack
fortunately the determined time is
running out
really not much time to work with okay
my plan is Bishop h6 f4 f5 yeah a five
coming if I five I think I'll take a
five
hey Favre whoa Thomas three instant
gifting subs thanks so much Thomas okay
I have to focus on the game but I'll
read the some names afterwards
it's like Queen g5 to put as many pieces
as possible to attack maybe I should see
for defending and attacking training
this
oh there's beautiful bow ties gambit
which leads to mates it's kind of a
knock see [ __ ] but okay I can take my
sakura gakuin not quite let's play this
move I want to do this 16 seconds left
not enough time can take this takes
takes oh this is complicated let's move
back whoa take stakes okay now it's no
longer about the tournament win it's
about just winning this game
it's gonna be very difficult to play
this move oh dear they're there
let's move king h2 okay now I have the
battery hmm I'll play Bishop g5 okay
lots of things attacking the knight I
can take the pawn it's complicated okay
let's take that thing which of each six
oh let's take this thing I'm stacking
everything I hope its mate I really hope
it's meat it's not gonna be mates da
take this thing no let's oh that's not
even working I'm actually sacking
everything uh-oh
this is not gonna be good oh let's get
some F sin the chance that's what's sad
what to do I tried I really there's a
beautiful line than that game I was
already like dreaming of it before it
happened this position yeah it was this
position if Knight takes Knight takes e4
looks attractive I would sack a queen
and then just meets opponent played good
move Bishop takes e4 it's a defended and
my ideas aren't working as well here of
course I want to take what the bishop
was in the way I had broke out five open
and still Bishop takes Knight spinned
anything for whites
stockfish not impressed taki welcome
back night CA thanks again for the bits
Thomas Benson gifting subs to Favre
diamond cutter young rolf magic 88 and a
jack supports
thanks so much Thomas that was a rough
finish maybe that will go on YouTube I
mean there's still some I think some
youtuber the contents